[Music]
I'm so grateful that the Academy
acknowledged its work
Laverne Cox turned heads at Sunday's
creative arts Emmys the orange is the
new black star was nominated for
Outstanding Guest Actress in a Drama
this storyline from season four voyages
through Blackman so much to me and I I
wanted to UM
I wanted to get it right as much as
possible because there are trans people
cancer to people all over the country
who are incarcerated who were spending
most of their time in solitary
confinement et also spoke to Cox about
becoming one of the new faces of queen
bees activewear line it's Beyonce girl
would you react to something like that
when we got the call it was I was like
it's a scream you scream you scream and
then it's like okay I got a I got a
workout Carter and prep so we do this
photo shoot we like bring it the way
that B deserves and move the way Ivy
Park deserves when Ivy Park came out in
the spring of 2016 I was in Toronto
shooting Rocky Horror Picture Show and I
don't know if you remember the way or a
park video from a girl I girl that video
came out and I was in hair and makeup
with deja my makeup artist and I played
it and played it like 20 times in like
five minutes and I was just like when I
was crying because I was in this I was
shooting this movie that was the hard
thing I've ever done before it was
physical I was singing I was dancing and
I've been sick I'm gonna go to that park
in my head Beyonce's been such a huge
inspiration for me like no no no no no
money I was always yes yes yes yes yes
it's incredible that she would choose me
to be the face of her fall campaign for
every part so thank you be I love
you know I love you everybody knows I
love her me and you both our stands
we're part of the Beehive right